this episode of the wi files is brought
to you by PDS
Deb the accepted narrative describes the
knight's Templar as humble Warrior monks
protecting Christians on the road to
Jerusalem the knights were later
betrayed and ultimately
destroyed but there is another story
within that story it's a legend filled
with murder mystery and Buried Treasure
and it involves a secret powerful enough
to rewrite history and change the world
yes the Templars were in Jerusalem
protecting Christians but that was their
cover Story the real reason they were
there was they were looking for
something ancient technology so as soon
as the night's Templar arrived in the
holy land they started digging and
[Music]
then yeah I know see more but it's only
for a couple of days human I'm not going
to beat her around the bush I need some
care
well hello to you too no time for
chitchat Gertie wants to go to St Barts
for Valentine's Day St Barts it's a
Caribbean Island I know what it is isn't
it like $1,700 a night whatever my baby
wants my baby gets anyway the beavers
and I are starting a business and they
need a little money to get going that's
where you come in human no way how many
times do I have to tell hear me out I'm
having a hard enough time making my
monthly credit card payments as it is
then gas hump supplies camel Chow you've
seen how much Gertie eats it's fine baby
I don't mind a little junk in the hump
anyway I can't keep up I just need a
teeny tiny weeny teeny tiny investment
say uh uh 40 G's 40,000 okay 45
absolutely not oh come on you'll love
this new business it's called Beaver box
we ship wood and wood products for
Valentine's Day the Beavers are nor
custom woodshaped hot pins you wear it
for your significant other family
friends whoever uh right now I got a
hard on for you did you say you have a
heart on yeah yeah you what probably
want to change the look people are going
to be buying these wood hot pins like
crazy everyone you love can have a hot
on please stop saying it saying what
look why don't you just have PDS take
care of your debt oh I think you just
shimmed your way into the day's sponsor
I sure did PDS has options for anyone
struggling with a lot of monthly debt
payments credit cards personal loans
collections medical bills everyone with
over $10,000 or more in eligible debt
qualifies well if I had good credit I
wouldn't be bugging you for a loan well
there's no minimum credit score required
good and Fair Credit is accepted they
roll your debt into one low with monthly
payment you can save thousands in
interest and fees and pay off your debt
in a fraction of the time I am liking
the sound of this PDS is also giving our
qualified viewers of free debt analysis
just for completing the 30C online
assessment at
www.ps.com
files PD sde
ebt.com files you got it when it sounds
perfect I'll sign up after the beavers
are done filling the beaver boxes with
wood yeah I I'm uncomfortable the way
wait where are you getting the wood oh
there was a bunch of it in the garage
the beaver say it's delicious that's the
new hardwood flooring for the kitchen
well I'm sorry Beav is going to Beaver
from now on you just let me know anytime
you get wood uh I my wife's going to
kill me how don't worry about it when
she sees these pins she'll forget you
you know what I'll have the boys car of
an extra large pin for you to wear that
way when she gets home you'll have a
huge hot on for
[Music]
her the Knights Templar were formed in
11:18 at least that's when they were
officially formed the real story began
many years earlier in Constantinople now
Istanbul Istanbul was Constantinople now
it's Istanbul that Constantinople been a
long time G Constantinople but
Constantinople get the works there
nobody's business but the
T what tell me that song didn't pop into
your head the second you said it it did
but you might
[Music]
havean
the brothers of the East was a Secret
order formed in Greece that eventually
set up their headquarters in Istanbul
they practiced Alchemy they studied
sacred geometry they performed rights
and rituals incorporating astrology
astronomy music and Mathematics so when
huep pays a French nobleman met the
brothers of the East he was excited
depay was technically Catholic as most
of Europe was but he had family members
who were of the Sufi Islamic faith which
is the more mystical side of
Islam the pains have been told of this
secret group that possessed and was
protecting ancient knowledge he wanted
to meet this group and see for himself
at this time in history Europe was in
chaos various kingdoms were rising and
falling and Waring with each other in
the East Muslims and Christians were
clashing the world was tearing itself
apart yet the brothers of the East
possessed a peaceful wisdom they weren't
concerned with modern Politics the
brothers had a purpose that was much
more important once Mutual trust was
established the brothers of the East
told the European visitors their story
well not their story the
story it was the story story of an
ancient civilization that thrived
thousands of years ago the people were
highly spiritual and highly Advanced it
was a civilization that was free of
poverty wealth was meaningless they
devised methods of growing crops so that
every citizen was fed they could control
the weather droughts and famine were
impossible to huip pays this
civilization had abilities that sounded
like Miracles or like sorcery they could
communicate over long distances in
instantly somehow they had a way of
levitating objects no matter how large
or how heavy they had medicine that
could cure any illness allowing people
to live very long lives War didn't exist
there was such an abundance of resources
that anyone can have whatever they
wanted and what these people wanted most
was to pursue their own spirituality and
then they were
gone how depay's asked could a
civilization this powerful who seem to
be able able to control nature itself be
suddenly wiped
[Music]
out the brothers of the East said in a
single day the ground Shook and
volcanoes emerged and erupted then a
giant flood swept over the Earth and
destroyed everything I know where this
is going it was then that hudep pays and
his eight Knights learned of Atlantis
YY
Hugh depay and his fellow Knights were
riveted by the story depay was a
nobleman aant fact he was the count of
champagne Le
champag oh pardon my
French depay's was an educated man he
knew about Plato and his stories of the
island of Atlantis he thought they were
just Stories the brothers said Plato was
mostly correct but Atlantis wasn't just
a city or even just an island it it was
a civilization that spanned the globe
and each city was connected using
transportation technology that again
sounded like magic the story became
almost overwhelming almost the brothers
said that ancient relics of Atlantis
still exist and they still possess their
power the power to travel great
distances the power of communication the
power to heal perhaps even the secret to
immortality if ever discovered these
artifacts would be the most powerful and
dangerous devices on Earth depay said
that any Kingdom any country any
religion would kill to have access to
this power the brothers of the East
agreed the technology of Atlantis could
not fall into the wrong hands so HUD
toay was offered an assignment find the
ancient artifacts and bring them back to
Europe for
safekeeping Hugh and the other eight men
immediately agreed and formed a secret
Fellowship but where do they start
looking
looking the brothers said they'll find
artifacts under the location of what
used to be King Solomon's Temple the
Temple mount in
Jerusalem the knights would have to act
quickly the holy land was a dangerous
place Jerusalem was taken by Christian
Crusaders in 1099 but who knows how long
they can hold it and there was another
problem it wasn't just the knights that
knew about the artifacts groups of
Christians Jews Muslims they were
searching too so when the knights
arrived in the Holy Land in 11:20 they
set up their headquarters where
Solomon's Temple once stood they
officially became known as poor fellow
Soldiers of Christ and the Temple of
Solomon the knight's
Templar and the Knights played the role
of courageous Warrior monks protecting
Christians making the long pilgrimage to
the Holy Land but while some Knights
Templar guarded Jerusalem other Knights
were digging beneath it day and night
they dug until one day they struck gold
literally the brothers of the East were
right they promised the knight's Templar
that if they dug under the Temple Mount
they would find artifacts that once
belonged to the great civilization of
Atlantis the knights found a large box
made of AAA wood and gold there was no
question they had found the legendary
Ark of the Covenant and then they found
five
more
[Music]
year after year the Knights Templar
pulled Treasures from beneath Jerusalem
they found the Spear of Destiny the Holy
Grail The Emerald Tablet and pages and
pages of ancient esoteric wisdom they
learned there were 10 arcs though they
only found six the arcs were used in
conjunction with pyramids around the
world to create Limitless energy this
was similar to what Nicola Tesla
attempted at Warden Cliff Tower if you
want to learn how this technology worked
we have an episode that explains
scientifically how the Great Pyramid of
Giza could have been a power generator
pyramid link
below within the king's chamber of the
Great Pyramid is a stone box mainstream
egyptology says this box is a
sarcophagus to store a mummy but no
mummy was ever found there and the
dimensions of the Box are kind of small
for a human body but the box is the
perfect size to store one of the arcs
the Knights Templar discovered that the
pyramids were built for one specific
purpose to store the arcs and the arcs
they were built to store
Mana in the Bible Mana was a food source
that appeared to the Israelites in the
desert it's described as fine flakes
that look like frost on the ground but
according to Templar tradition the
Israelites and the atlantans before them
extracted Mana from plant and animal
matter and turned it into a monoatomic
white powder this white powder provides
Ides energy a white powder that provides
energy ah New York in the80s was wild eh
uh you're thinking about something else
ah the Mana acted as an electrical
superconductor and powered the arcs
inside the pyramids the arcs generated
unlimited energy for the thriving
civilization they learned these
alchemical secrets from none other than
the Emerald Tablet Emerald Tablet link
below the Emerald Tablet gave detailed
instructions on extracting Mana from
animal bones the Mana could then be used
for energy or even for healing illness
hey didn't the Emerald Tablet also tell
you how to become a mortal by making the
uh philosopher stone yep from eating pee
yes eating lots of pee yes immortality
sounds gross it does but if you want to
be a mortal ain't no such thing as a
free lunch nope even if lunch is PE
that's
[Music]
enough some of these ancient texts even
talked about creating Mana from gold
when mono was extracted from gold it
could be used to make objects lighter
for levitation now think about it the
ark is a box almost 4T long and 3 ft
wide it's made of gold gold is heavy the
Ark of the Covenant also contain the Ten
Commandments which were carved into
stone tablets stone is heavy just the
gold would have weighed almost 1,000 lb
that doesn't include the weight of the
stone or the acacia wood yet it only
took four men to carry it by the way the
men who carried the ark were Levites
levite levitation I get a covenant link
below the Knights Templar also found
very old texts that even predated the
civilization of Atlantis these documents
spoke of a non-human race that enslaved
Humanity thousands of years ago to M
gold
Yi the the Anunnaki come up a lot on
this channel and I promise I'll do a
full episode on them but here's the
short version the Anunnaki were Gods
worshiped by the ancient samarians but
they were actually aliens from a planet
Beyond Neptune called Nibiru the
Anunnaki arrived on Earth about 450,000
years ago searching for resources
specifically gold they were trying to
solve an atmospheric crisis on their
planet now finding gold in abundance
they settled on Earth and established
mining operations
eventually the Anunnaki created a labor
force by genetically modifying early
human ancestors accelerating the
evolution of homo sapiens we need this
episode Chief I know we'll do it I
promise yeah yeah yeah your promises in
60 bucks are worth about one night's
worth of Mana
okay so the Templars knew about the
anunaki and how they converted gold into
a powder used for healing levitation and
generating electricity and it wasn't
just the Atlant Ian and Israelites that
knew about
Mana Samaran texts spoke of an
alchemical science called Graal which
you can't help but notice is similar to
the word Grail the samarians use a
substance called shimana that was used
to help the Anunnaki Gods power their
flying craft in vitic Hindu and Jane
texts this substance was called Thea
which again was used to power flying
crafts Polynesian cultures believe Mana
is a force of nature anyone can extract
Buddhists call it Mani though the words
vary slightly in all these cultures the
definition and use are the same Mana is
a potent substance that allows Humanity
to tap into something very powerful in
nature and by the way the Templar cross
you can find that carved everywhere and
every time civilization existed the
cross is all over ancient Egypt you can
even see the cross carved on the ancient
Samaran depictions of the Anunnaki
Templar Legend says this was was
actually the symbol of Atlantis after
Atlantis was destroyed in the great
flood love the young
Adas yep the Templar Legend of Atlantis
and the great flood is exactly like
every other flood myth we find in every
culture around the world after the flood
a few survivors restarted civilization
with knowledge from Atlantis the cross
was carved in their honor but not
everything the knights found was
Atlantean some artifacts were from just
a thousand years before during the time
of Jesus there were ancient texts that
confirmed a lot of what was said in the
Bible but some texts contradicted the
Bible there was no way the knights could
let the church find out what they
discovered the Catholic church was
growing more powerful every year if the
truth came out it could shake the very
foundation of the faith and the knight's
Templar would be destroyed besides much
of the knight's funding came from the
church but no historical document
compared to the shock of what they
discovered next and assary which is a
collection of Bones this Asar held the
bones of a very famous religious family
all buried together the knights found
the bones of Mary Magdalene John the
Baptist and Jesus himself but they also
found the bones of the children Mary had
with both of
[Music]
them to call what the Knights Templar
discovered Blasphemous would be a huge
understatement they discover documents
artifacts that would literally destroy
the church they needed to keep these
Treasures safe from being destroyed they
needed to keep them from falling into
the wrong hands specifically the Pope's
hands the Templars knew that the
existence of the bones of John Jesus and
Mary Magdalene and their children would
mean the end of the Catholic church but
to rub salt in an already gaping wound
the Templars found something potentially
even more threatening to the church an
alternate belief
system the Templars were Christian but
not in the strictest sense as most of
Europe was and more importantly as their
King and employers were spreading
information contrary to the teachings of
the Catholic church was not only heresy
it was a death sentence remember this
was all happening at the time of the
Crusades religions were at
War the Templars couldn't speak about
their findings but couldn't ignore them
either so so instead they hid them they
protected them and studied them some
ancient wisdom included Blasphemous
ideas like the divine feminine
reincarnation Heaven as a state of mind
and an innate connection to the Creator
the knights maintain their appearance as
devout Catholics they had to their
biggest Patron was the Catholic Church
you don't bite the hand that feeds you
especially the most powerful hand on
Earth but in secret the Knights Templar
were Christian
gnostics gnosticism comes from the Greek
word nosis meaning Divine knowledge
other cultures call this Enlightenment
the basic premise is that spirituality
can be found within without needing an
outside institution so no reason to have
priests monks saviors or churches at all
you didn't need them to find God he's
already within you one of the earliest
Templar documents mentions god-given
rights now Americans use this phrase or
something close to it in the Declaration
of Independence but that was in the 18th
century the idea of god-given rights
during the time of the Templars meant
excommunication or
Worse only the Roman Church could give
someone rights any alternative was bad
for business and instead of worshiping
Jesus many Knights Templar idolized John
the Baptist who they believe initiated
Jesus into gnosticism in the Great
Pyramid to the Templars Jesus
represented Ed a Christos a universal
Consciousness anyone could access
similar to the Buddha they learned that
being born again didn't refer to baptism
it referred to reincarnation which
someone would literally be born
again with the bones of Jesus sacred
documents and artifacts from an ancient
civilization the Templars had plenty of
evidence to back up their beliefs they
wanted to share this knowledge but it
wasn't the right time the church was too
powerful they would have to wait they
would wait until this knowledge could be
shared with the entire world and not
seized by one Pope or one king So after
years of digging these early Knights
returned to Europe with the treasures
and knowledge and hid it and then they
built an
empire for 200 years the Knights Templar
grew and thrived their numbers increased
from a handful of soldiers to tens of
thousands of men and women the Catholic
church and Christian Lords throughout
Europe gave the Knights Templar money
land and power to help their cause the
Templars created Cathedrals power
structures and systems of democracy they
created the first banking system a
system we still use today during the
Dark Ages the journey from Europe to
Jerusalem was dangerous road agents were
robbing the pilgrims of everything they
had so the Knights Templar set up
locations along the way called
commanderies and anyone of these
locations you could deposit your gold
and exchange for a note you then take
this note to another commander and
exchange it for gold and for every
transaction the knight's Templar charged
a small fee it was an ingenious system
used by thousands of people for hundreds
of years over time those little fees
added
up now individually the knight's Rapport
when joining you gave all your wealth to
the order the order then took care of
you and all its members the treasures
and knowledge passed from generation to
generation with each Grandmaster
responsible for their
safekeeping and for those few hundred
years the Knights Templar were extremely
successful at distracting the church
from their true purpose a little too
successful eventually the Knights
Templar had their own armies their own
fleets of ships they had their own
Merchants Masons and Farmers they were
independent and self- sustaining the
Knights Templar became the first
multinational corporation they had no
need for a king or country in fact the
opposite happened the Knights Templar
were so wealthy that King Philip of
France was borrowing money from them in
the fall of 1307 King Philip IV needed
financing for another War he wasn't
going to borrow any more money from the
knights instead he would take it from
them the Templars had gone from Humble
Defenders of Christianity to a serious
threat to the entire power structure of
Europe the king and the church and like
many powerful rulers King Philip didn't
tolerate threats so Philip and Pope
clemont V devised a
plan Pope clont by the way was born
Raymond Bertrand and was a childhood
friend of the king when the previous
Pope died in 1304 King philli made sure
his friend was elected to what was one
of the most powerful seats of power on
Earth in short the pope owed him one
on Friday the 13th of October
1307 100 Templars including The
Grandmaster jacqu de mle were arrested
for 7 years they were threatened and
tortured to try to gain access to their
knowledge and wealth after making false
confessions they were found guilty of
heresy and sentenced to death but now
there's a plot twist for centuries
history claimed the church had condemned
the Knights Templar as Heretics and
eventually had them executed but in 2001
a document was found in the Vatican
secret archives it's called the shanon
parchment the shenon parchment
documented the inquiry led by three
Cardinals appointed by Pope clemont V it
details the investigation and the
charges against the Templar leaders
including The Grandmaster jacqu deay the
shenon parchment reveals that the pope
absolve the Templar leaders of heresy
they were allowed to reconcile with the
church the pope would allow the order of
the Knights Templar to continue their
work King Phillip didn't like this
result he applied pressure to the pope
remember the pope owed him one so in
1312 Pope clemont officially disbanded
the knight's Templar the leaders of the
order including jacqu de moay were later
burned at the stake on charges of heresy
even though they were forgiven of these
crimes but Grandmaster jacqu deole would
enact a small token of Revenge for this
betrayal of Justice
as he slowly burned to death mle issued
a curse to the pope and the King of
France he promised them that they would
be dead within a year this was March of
1314 a few weeks later Pope clont was
dead according to One account while
lying in state he was struck by
lightning the fire was so intense that
his body was unrecognizable and if you
read up on this Pope you'll agree that
this was divine Justice in November King
philli had a stroke and died he was 46
years old the Templar curse was
fulfilled France had now lost its king
and its Pope and Europe had lost their
beloved Knights or so it
seemed when the arrest order was given
on October 13th the Knights Templar knew
it was coming they had spies everywhere
they had known for weeks and they used
those weeks to plan on October 12th the
night before the arrest order was given
the templar's entire fleet of ships
disappeared appeared into the darkness
and aboard those ships were all the
ancient Atlantean artifacts the holy
treasures and forbidden documents Jac de
Malay and about a 100 Knights stayed
behind they hoped they could reason with
the king and the pope they failed in
that mission but succeeded in another
disbanded but not destroyed in hiding
but not in prison the Templars formed
into smaller groups they assimilated
into other orders some assumed new
identities and disappeared all together
the knight's Templar in name ended in
1312 but their mission continued in fact
it continues today the evidence is
everywhere evidence of the knights
Templer can be found all over the world
after they disbanded they were
determined to keep their knowledge and
traditions alive so they created Alias
groups to avoid detection in Scotland
they became Freemasons Portugal they
were known as the Knights of Christ in
Germany they created
Rosicrucianism there's also evidence of
them in the early Americas Nova Scotia
has the legendary Oak Island with buried
Templar treasure and deadly curses an
indigenous tribe in Panama known as the
White Indians of Daran have pale skin
and Caucasian features some believe
their descendants of the first Templars
in the Americas when asked about the
knight's Templar the natives called them
our brother others in early Europe
Templars were the first Vikings the
first Pirates were knights's Templar the
famous skull and crossbone symbol the
Jolly Roger that flag was first flown by
the Templar Navy to frighten their
enemies before battle one of the most
famous Templer symbols is the Red Cross
with a white background another is the
depiction of several Knights on a horse
like this statue in London both of these
are found in cathedrals and chapels all
across
Europe if you read saw The Da Vinci Code
you may remember Roslin Chapel in
Scotland Pagan and Templar symbols are
on every inch of it some like this
carving of a knight on Horseback are
obvious this is the gravestone for
William Sinclair it's in the lower part
of Rosland Chapel it specifically says
KN
Templar Williams Sinclair had no love
for the church and provided help to any
Knights Templar who asked for it but
it's not just crosses and horses that
the knights engraved on their
architecture there are more subtle Clues
relating to some of their Gnostic and
sometimes Pagan beliefs sculptures of
angels and strange positions are common
in Rosland chapel and are an important
right in Freemasonry but Freemasonry
wasn't supposed to have started until
1717 rosin Chapel was built in
1446 over 100 of these little green men
are scattered around Rosland Chapel
they're Pagan symbols and thought to
originate from ancient Celtics paganism
simply refers to anything that isn't
Christian Muslim or Jewish why would
there be hundreds of non-Christian
symbols in a Catholic Church Templar
Legend says they were placed there as a
message some of the more interesting
carvings are of plants that Europeans
never should have known
about this is a picture of corn over one
of the windows in Rosland chapel and
here's one of Trillium but corn and
Trillium are native to North America
rosin Chapel was built almost 50 years
before Columbus sailed to the new world
how would Templars know what these
plants look like well isn't it obvious
they were there
first Templar Legend says Sir Henry
Sinclair grandfather of the Builder of
Rosland Chapel was not only a Templar
but was among the first Europeans to
visit the new world not only that but
Christopher Columbus himself was
associated with the Knights he was a
distant relative of the Sinclair's
Columbus's daughter was married to The
Grandmaster of the order he had access
as all Grand Masters do to ancient
knowledge of the Knights Templar
including their Maps Columbus knew there
was something on the other side of the
Atlantic he didn't know what but he knew
there was land and treasure he knew this
because the knight's Templar had Maps
the new world for centuries one of these
was the per Reese map and you know this
famous map it shows the new world and
Antarctica hundreds of years before they
were rediscovered per Reese by the way
was a cartographer from Istanbul which
in his time was Constantinople
birthplace of the Knights Templar was
pures a Templar maybe coincidence maybe
but when Columbus wanted to sail to the
new world he first approached King John
of Portugal for financing King John
refused so Columbus went to Portugal's
enemies Spain and England Queen isab
Bella of Spain came up with the money
first and the rest is history but
Templar history tells a different story
they say Portugal refused to finance
Columbus because they already knew about
the new world Knights Templar had been
sailing there for years Portugal was
populated by so many Knights that it was
considered a Templar nation in fact the
word Portugal means Port of the Galls
but Templars say it really means Port of
the Grail
ah Knights Templar history says they
were trading with Native American tribes
for years that's where they got a lot of
their gold and the Templars had a very
good relationship with the people of the
new world Columbus knew this how do we
know well when Columbus sailed the ocean
blue in 1492 the N the Pinta and the
Santa Maria all flew flags with the
Templar
cross he knew the natives would
recognize this symbol and be peaceful
and they were at first sadly the
Europeans didn't return the favor the
Knights Templars say they were the first
Europeans to visit the Americas fine but
can they prove it they
can in 1898 Olaf Omen was clearing land
on his farm in Minnesota when he
stumbled upon a strange looking
rock it was a tablet about 30 in tall
and 16 in wide carved in it were symbols
that Omen didn't recognize this tablet
became known as the Kensington runestone
Omen had it analyzed and translated the
inscription said it was left by Viking
Travelers in
1362 and this isn't a stone found on the
coast these Vikings were in the middle
of the continent Vikings in the new
world a century before
Columbus now remember according to
Templar tradition the first Vikings were
Knights Templar then there's the
narraganset runstone found in Rhode
Island in 1939 also with Viking
runes only 14 mil from where this
runstone was discovered is Newport Tower
this is a mysterious 8 column structure
it's rumored to have been built by
Vikings in the 1500s to track the
solstices the local Museum says it's
just the base of a lighthouse but most
locals disagree as far back as the early
1800s records and legends have given
credit to Vikings but why eight columns
why not just build it as one solid
cylinder well the answer leads us back
to gnosticism the number eight is highly
significant to gnostics it represents
completeness a Divine fullness remember
earlier when I mentioned Jesus was
initiated in the Great Pyramid well
there's a reason for that if you watch
the episode that we had about the
pyramids link below you'll remember that
the Great Pyramid has eight sides not
four to this day Templars are initiated
in the Great Pyramid and they believe
that Egypt was one of the main sources
of wisdom for the original Knights and
if you look the number eight is
everywhere in Templar symbolism and
architecture the maltes cross has eight
points and was worn by a medial order of
knights that were attacked by fire today
it's the symbol of many firefighters
yeah shout out to NFD New York's bravest
H you're here buildings like Temple
Church and elely cathedral in England
have octogonal features and the number
eight scattered all over the place you
only have to look at a few pictures of
rosin Chapel to start seeing the numbers
showing up again and again evidence of
the Knights Templar is everywhere now we
can't cover the knights without
mentioning the Freemasons countless
rights symbols and beliefs connect the
two groups almost seamlessly Masons
Trace their Origins back to the Temple
of Solomon just like the Templars on Oak
Island Nova Scotia a money pit was
discovered in 1795 along with a Templar
engraving since then the Freemasons have
been involved in almost every search for
the Lost Treasure both Masonic symbols
and Templar crosses are scattered across
cross the island the connection between
the groups is so deep that they still
see each other as brothers to this
day another Templar connection is with
Rosicrucianism which heavily emphasizes
the rose and the cross both Templar
symbols but why why did the Templars
spend so much time and money hiding
their
legacy well the Knights Templar had a
higher purpose their ultimate goal was
to change the world for the better they
knew the ancient artifacts and knowledge
would be a shock to Society but this
knowledge was never meant to stay hidden
eventually the knights will share the
truth and the truth might come out
sooner than you
think Timothy Hogan is the current
grandmas of one of the Templar orders
he's on a mission to prepare the world
to embrace their secrets he insists that
this knowledge is powerful enough to
drastically alter our society as we know
it in a positive way currently all the
Templar Treasures are hidden inv vaults
around the world seven of which are here
in the United States and according to
Hogan the world is just about ready for
their release he says they'll do it in a
way where no one government no one
religion will have complete access to
the information the release of
information will be controlled to ensure
everyone benefits because really that's
the templar's entire purpose it has been
since the beginning they wanted freedom
for the people physical Freedom From The
King and spiritual freedom from the Pope
unfortunately it wasn't possible in the
14th century but today it could very
well succeed we're at a pivotal point in
history where many feel like something
is about to happen they just don't know
what and I feel it too now that might be
nothing more than Humanity's obsession
with death and the end of the world but
maybe it's more than that I think we all
know that we can't go on living this way
constant Wars around the world the
hatred within our countries the
dishonesty of our leaders the corruption
of our instit tions it has to stop
imagine how different our lives would be
if we had access to ancient wisdom and
Technology it would be a revolution we
could finally do what Nicola Tesla
almost did create free energy for the
entire planet it would take a while but
eventually everyone on Earth could
access healthy food clean water and live
long healthy lives free of illness and
pain it would be a revolution crime
poverty and War wouldn't be necessary in
a world of abundance
all due to the artifacts being held in
secret vaults around the world it would
be a
revolution that is if they're
[Music]
real today's story of the night's
Templar comes from one man Timothy Hogan
he's The Grandmaster of the order of the
Temple of secret initiates the otsi he
tells the story of ancient wisdom
Alchemy holy relics and Atlantean
artifacts it's a fascinating story but
is it true well there's nothing to
debunk about his story but there's also
no physical evidence to prove it so it
really comes down to Mr Hogan do you
believe him now you know what I'm going
to call him Tim because I know he's
watching hi Tim this is the part of the
episode where I tell you all the
positive and negative things I can about
the author of the story but today we
have to do things a little differently
recently on live streams I've been cold
reading rough drafts of script for this
channel you probably assume this but I
have a team of writers researchers and
contributors because well I I need to my
cute 12-minute videos about weird
animals have now become 40-minute
documentaries I'm just a guy who talks
to a fish I need help anyway when I read
the scripts live I'm literally reading
them for the first time along with you
obviously they're never final scripts I
rewrite everything I'm given I also
research and fact check as much as I
can oh yeah then this one has to put in
his jokes yeah you'd be nothing without
me well
nothing but here's where things took a
turn first after reading the draft I was
contacted by a viewer hi Stan Stan knows
Timothy Hogan he felt that the script
was unfair to him that it attacked him
too personally and you know what I think
Stan was right you can still see the
live read on the channel under the live
tab but here's the short version The
Script brought up Tim's divorce and a
situation he had with a woman who was
suffering from addiction and mental
illness she took over his Facebook page
and posted wild stuff as him like she
was The Reincarnation of Mary Magdalene
so that makes him Jesus and things like
that and look those things happened and
it's not a good look but are they
relevant to his story about the knight's
Templar absolutely not just like my exes
aren't relevant to the work I do now he
you got some real pieces of work in you
pissed I know some real pieces of work I
tell you I know I went through some
rough batches your wife is a saint I
can't deny that but that's the point
Tim's personal life is just that
personal and I don't really like gossip
okay I like gossip but I don't do it on
the channel well you do it on the live
streams okay that's fine let me get
through this so Tim's personal life is
irrelevant but his professional life
regarding his work with and as a
knight's Templar is relevant Tim has
detractors people that don't like him
people that don't believe him I asked
the researcher where she found these
people they're unreddit aren't they
they're unreddit they hate you unreddit
too oh they don't love you either fair
enough Tim's detractors are what seem to
be members of different orders of the
Knights Templar or other fraternal
organizations it's actually hard to
follow if you're not in that world now
people often ask me if I'm a mason or in
groups like that and I'm not and I joke
that I'm not a joiner I don't play well
with others because that's true so when
people talk about Grand Masters and
seventh degrees and secret handshake
grips and all that stuff I don't get it
I don't impune it but I really don't get
it but the people that are in those
groups do get it and they take it very
[Music]
seriously there's been infighting with
these various orders for a thousand
years and it's still happening this
board voted Tim off or that group wanted
him out he didn't like what another
group was doing so he left that kind of
thing are the internal politics of these
fraternal groups relevant to his story
of the Knights Templar to me no there
are people who call Tim a fraud that he
makes claims that aren't true well I'm
going to read you a few of his claims
and these are Tim's words in an email to
me laugh it up it's going to happen to
you too it was also suggested that I say
I'm a descendant of a revolutionary war
Templar which is actually true my
great-grandfather seven generations back
was General Joseph Warren of the
Revolutionary War true he initiated Paul
R and he helped plan the Boston Tea
Party he was an alchemist and a doctor a
Templar Grand Commander for the region
and his relationship with Paul Rivier
was largely based on studying Alchemy
Paul Rivier was a silver smith that's
true my grandfather H Warren also taught
Metallurgy at Denver University my
great-grandfather James bade Warren also
knew metalurgy and he was the Grand
lecturer for the Masonic Grand Lodge of
Pennsylvania and he was a grand
commander of the Knights Templar true my
my father was Steven de Hogan mayor of
Aurora Colorado and had been active in
politics my entire life he was also a
Templar there are highways and
Convention centers named after him in
Colorado true we continue covering
Colorado First at 5 and we travel to
Aurora when the city hosted a ground
breaking event for the Steven Hogan
Parkway project Clos about a 2 Mile gap
between existing six Parkway on the west
and E470 on the East but even though he
always had politics going on uh he
always tried to make time for us
individually and to to make us feel
special I ran for mayor after we passed
away in a special election and lost by
two votes anyhow my family on both sides
had been Templars and I was first kned
into the tradition at 8 years old as a
pagee now I've seen these claims
challenged online but everything I could
find says that Tim is telling the truth
about his family there are a few other
criticisms of him online that he
addressed in his emails to me I don't
find a lot of it relevant it's mostly
personal but Google him and decide for
yourself here's where I stand I've
watched and listen to interviews with
Tim that go back about 10 years I've
read two of his books well skimmed I
watched his entire series on Gaia which
is fascinating by the way Tim Hogan has
an encyclopedic knowledge of the history
of the Knights Templar names dates
meanings of words ancient rituals
everything connecting the knights to
ancient Egypt various pharaohs and kings
and and popes Tim knows it all and if
you're into this subject listen to one
of his interviews he's knowledgeable and
riveting and when we finally get the
studio finished here Tim agreed to come
in and talk to me and have his claims
challenged but what about his claims
well from what I gather and this is only
my opinion Tim will lean into
information depending on the situation
meaning if he's being interviewed by an
historian or someone focused on hard
facts Tim sticks to the facts he'll
bring up the theories and label them as
such Legend says or people say that sort
of thing if he's in a forum Where the
wild claims are expected he'll lean into
those now look I love Gaia I'm a paid
subscriber but everybody on that channel
believes everything and a lot of it is
bunk a lot of it but Gaia viewers want
the wild
stuff what was
Atlantis was it a place a culture and
what happened to it I'm Timothy Hogan
grandmas of the Knights Templar and I'm
Scott Walter A forensic geologist and a
Knights Templar and this is Mysteries of
the Knights
Templar I don't think Tim believes every
theory he discusses I think he's
intelligent and entertaining and I think
he caters to the
audience now at first that might sound
dishonest but it's exactly what I do
here I tell the story The Legend the
myth as it's meant to be told then we
break it down together I'm not trying to
to you I'm trying to entertain you I'm
not a journalist I talk to a fish we do
this for fun now there are some bold
claims that Tim sticks by like the
vaults containing the arcs and uies of
remains he says these are real he's seen
them and the information is coming out
the purpose of the show on Gaia is to in
Tim's words bring people up to speed
okay that's fair but that's not evidence
and bold claims need hard evidence I'm
going to be very honest one of my most
loyal patrons was upset about the Mary
Magdalene Jesus John part of the story
that's the uary the bones he felt it was
insulting to Christianity and I should
leave it out but it's such an explosive
claim I needed to tell you about it if I
left it out I'd feel like a liar and a
coward that said I did check with other
people of faith in my community they
said it's part of the story leave it in
and if you followed this channel for a
while you know that I greatly respect
religion and people of Faith well so uh
I mentioned the arcs uh accordingly we
also have uh aaries with the bones of
certain holy
figures that were hanging on to by the
way I've only seen Tim discuss that
story about the bones once and he was
reluctant to do so he knows it's touchy
well okay well you just can't get away
with without naming names aaries of whom
uh well what we they would be referred
to as the holy families so it would be
you know John the Baptist Jesus Mary
Magdalene and their kids he said he'll
allow DNA testing but he was also very
clear that he had no intention of
insulting anyone's Faith one of the
biggest hurdles that we're trying to get
over with all of this is that
uh we're not trying to invalidate
anybody's
beliefs uh we're just trying to say that
that there might be a little bit more to
the
story and I believe him on that point
Tim's been accused of doing so many
interviews and giving so many lectures
because he wants to sell books and get
people to watch his show does that mean
he's lying no he's promoting Graham
Hancock is everywhere when he has a book
out he wants people to buy it and read
it so what I'm a huge fan I buy all of
Graham's books and watch all of his
shows and interviews I've seen every
minute of him on Rogan I don't have to
believe everything Graham says but I
enjoy the material same with Tim Hogan
you don't have to believe his story to
enjoy it stories of Atlantean treasure
free energy and ancient documents that's
nothing new those Legends have been
around forever now they may be true but
until we have physical evidence they are
still Legends so is Tim just jumping on
the Atlantis bandwagon or is the link
between the Knights Templar and Atlantis
real are there really underground vaults
hidden around the world with ancient
technology that could rid us of poverty
and War the arcs the artifacts the
Emerald Tablet the Mana the bones are
they
real well I need to see them but if you
choose to believe the story without
physical proof that's okay too I'm not
trying to persuade you one way or
another Tim insists that the Templars
will reveal these artifacts very soon if
there are no artifacts why make that
promise when he talks about the Divine
in each of us he seems to believe it but
that could be my own bias because I also
believe that the Divine God the
universal energy the whatever you call
it I believe that is in each of us and I
don't think that belief has to
contradict anyone's Faith that's why
it's called faith if Tim Hogan is
telling the truth Humanity's future
might not be as doomed as we think and
maybe the Catalyst the change the
evidence we need is hiding in a vault
right now right beneath our feet I don't
know if it is but I truly hope
so
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's eckle fish
hey you don't happen to have a Mana guy
do you I don't this has been the wi
files if you had fun or learned anything
do us a favor like subscribe comment
share those buttons really help us out
and like most topics we cover on the
channel today's is recommended by you so
if there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the Wi files.com
tips and remember the yfiles is also a
podcast twice a week I post deep dives
into the stories we cover here on the
channel I also post episodes that
wouldn't be allowed on the channel
they're called unredacted podcast is
called the wi files operation podcast
and it's available everywhere you get
your podcasts now if you need more wi
files in your life check out our Discord
there are over 40,000 people on there
24/7 and they talk about the same weird
stuff that we do it's a great Community
it's a lot of fun and it's free to join
now the best way to keep track of all
the stuff that's happening with the
channel is the wi files.com Cal that's
our production calendar there you'll see
what episodes are being posted and when
the names of the podcasts when we're
live streaming all that stuff is there a
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible every episode of
the wi files is dedicated to our patreon
members I don't deserve the support that
you give but I'm truly grateful for it
without you there'd be no Channel now if
you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon
for as little as three bucks a month you
get access to perks like videos early
with no commercials access to merge only
available to Members Plus you get two
private live streams every week just for
you my camera's on your camera's on if
you want it's a lot of fun and it's a
great perk another great way to support
the channel is grab something from the
Wi-Fi store grab yourself a heck of his
T-shirt or a coffee mug you can stick
your fist in along with a beverage of
your choice or grab a hoodie with my
face on it or what of these squeezy
stuffed animal talking heck ofish tuing
fish
toy that's going to do it and next time
be safe be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
yeah I play Bia scaria 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I
should but then another conspiracy
theory becomes the truth my
friends and it never ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with MK truck I being
only true
aware did Stanley Cub Bri fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I
can't I'm dancing with the fish fish on
Thursday night Wednesday J
and through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth to
the all through the
[Music]
night
the MTH man SIDS and the solar storm
still come to a go the The Secret City
Underground mysterious number stations
Planet are to project State and what the
dark Watchers
found a simulation don't
you the black KN satellited to me so I
can't believe I'm dancing with the fish
heck fish on Thursday night W they J
when through the
night all ever what it was to just hear
the truth so the Fe all through the
night fish on Thursday night Wednesday J
my
all I ever want was to just hear the
truth
so all through
[Music]
the good enough to dance good to dance
good enough to dance goodie loves to
dance goody loves to dance on the
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is right on
way in time good love dance good love
[Music]
dance